smash your pants what a great idea of a
video I'm sure that's not going to have
any consequences whatsoever personally
or online you know it's not going to be
awkward when I meet these people in real
life after I judge them whether I would
stick my dick in them or not I think you
know it's such a [ __ ] good idea for
anyone over the age of [ __ ] 16 or
already [ __ ] age of that matter to
make its smash marry or sell to slavery
that's how we go I didn't make this list
by the way so keeping keep in mind
nothing personal okay take it take it
step-by-step here we go Jack stupid I
see starting off strong um hard pass
hard pass can among go sell to slavery
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god Tanna what are you how dare
you call me that work I'm above that
okay I don't use that I don't say the
n-word
okay I'm above that Sniper Wolf I would
give her the are Mac fatality
[Music]
what can I say I'm into kinky [ __ ]
Jessica Nigri more like Jessica no gree
sell that [ __ ] this ivory I'm kidding
I'm sorry
I mean sell that lady's slavery
[Music]
markiplier I would give the fattest dick
I would love to have a non-sexual
relationship with mark where we just
Eskimo kiss and sometimes finger each
other spot home ksi thousand slavery Oh
Dan and Phil this is fun I'm enjoying
this I'm just judging the [ __ ] out of
people let's see here dan and Phil hmm I
would sell up just library please
actually I would marry Koh seems lovely
Dan however
yeah yes so Dan to slavery hey humming
there oh oh man what can I say I would I
would then give the fattest dick super
ma woman would slash with that
sledgehammer why does everyone have it
against me I don't I understand you
don't understand filthy Frank wait who's
that sexy Phil I would just have a
serious talk about your username I would
pretend to befriend you and then just
stab you in the back
zoella scorpion fatality I'm gonna have
to go with scorpion fatality on that one
I would have a ride write my book my
next my next book I will have her write
it keemstar sell to slavery Oh what what
wait oh keemstar South slavery please
hello Alex
yeah yeah he's on the market man yeah
okay
got a good price for you 18 18 no no no
no no don't hang out god damn it jenna
Marbles I would smash that like button I
love her videos I'm threading it trying
to really hurt myself marina got I would
dance I would dance with marina Zoe
Berger I would I would have a damn drink
cyanide with Zooey rice gum
so just slavery quick no actually then
you reasonably like get exposed for
having like a ghost riders for Hurley's
dis dis track then you get exposed for
hue botting as well and then there's all
fouseytube thing that happened it's
getting exposed for everything what's
next is he's not Asian is that what he's
actually white Marcia OH
that's easy pass big much yes
[Music]
but much so [ __ ] hard look at that
trick I would take that white [ __ ] to
Starbucks rosebush that take your
[ __ ] knife sorry what happened that
was smash or pass would you smash or
pass me live a comment down below what
you would do to the space watch another
video that way this video get will get
more promotion is how the algorithm
works don't like the video [ __ ] dope
don't stop just click here go just go go
ahh